[S01] 就在此刻，呃，在你最常用的一款手机应用的数据库里，五秒前刚刚写入的一条最新状态，正和五年前存进去的古董数据，就这么静静地躺在一起。
[S02] 没错，而且后台运行的同一套服务器代码，它必须得能完美无瑕地同时理解处理它们俩。稍微出一点差错，系统可能就会直接宕掉。
[S01] 对，你仔细琢磨一下，这其实是一件极其不可思议的事情。
[S02] 这确实是软件工程里最迷人也最让人头疼的现实。你想，物理世界里的建筑一旦落成，它的结构基本就定型了。
[S01] 嗯，除非你把它拆了重建。
[S02] 对，但数据系统不是，它是一个活的生命体。你的代码每天都在迭代，业务逻辑可能每小时都在变。在这种剧烈的变化中，如何保证新旧系统交替的时候不散架，就是我们今天要面对的核心挑战。
[S01] 所以，欢迎加入本次深度解析。今天我们的任务呢，就是为你彻底破解系统平滑演化的底层密码。我们将深入挖掘一本被无数工程师奉为圭臬的经典资料，《设计数据密集型应用》，也就是大家常说的 DDIA。
[S02] 尤其是里面极具启发性的第五章，编码与演化。
[S01] 对，就是这一章。那么在探究这一切之前呢，所有的呃数据演化其实都始于一个极其基础，却常常暗藏杀机的动作。
[S02] 把内存里的东西变字节。
[S01] 对，就是把内存里生动鲜活的东西，比如那些复杂的结构体啊，哈希表啊、树啊，硬生生地压扁，转化成一串连续的字节序列。因为只有这样，数据才能通过网络电缆发送，或者存进你的硬盘里。
[S02] 这个过程我们一般叫它编码或者序列化。你要知道，当数据待在内存中的时候，它是专门为CPU 优化过的，里面充满了各种错综复杂的指针和内存引用。
[S01] 但网络电缆是不认识什么指针的呀。
[S02] 对，所以必须打包。那么这里最容易踩进去的第一个陷阱，就是很多开发者为了图省事，直接拿编程语言内置的序列化工具来用。
[S01] 呃，比如Java的那个序列化或者Python的pickle？
[S02] 没错，听起来很顺手，对吧？不需要引入任何第三方库，敲几行代码，就能把一个极其复杂的内存对象直接落盘。
[S01] 听起来简直太棒了，但是我知道肯定有个但是。
[S02] 但是你为此支付的代价，其实是你系统未来的生存空间。首先，这等同于把你未来的整个微服务架构，死死绑在了这一种特定的编程语言上。
[S01] 哦，也就是说，如果你以后想用Go 或者 Rust重写某个高性能模块，
[S02] 你会发现，他们根本读不懂那些特定语言打包出来的数据，完全是鸡同鸭讲。
[S01] 这确实是个大坑。而且我还注意到，在这个资料的评论区里，底下的程序员都在疯狂吐槽，说Java内置的那个序列化出来的字节体积极其臃肿，性能更是差的离谱。
[S02] 却还不算最糟的。更致命的是，安全隐患。为了能完美还原出之前的对象，这些语言内置的反序列化机制，通常被设计成能够实例化任意类。
[S01] 等等，实例化任意类。那如果有黑客恶意攻击呢？
[S02] 对啊，如果黑客向你的端口发送了一段精心构造的有害字节序列，你的程序在反序列化的时候，就会乖乖地把这些恶意代码实例化，并且在系统里执行。
[S01] 哇，这等于是你不仅帮小偷开了门，还主动帮他把开锁工具组装好了，太可怕了。
[S02] 所以大家自然就会转向跨语言的通用文本格式，比如JSON、XML或者CSV。它们不仅跨语言，而且呃人类肉眼可读。
[S01] 文本格式确实给人一种透明、安全的错觉。但其实就拿目前最流行的JSON来说吧，它虽然区分字符串和数字，却根本不区分整数和浮点数。
[S02] 没错，这是一个巨大的隐患。
[S01] 更可怕的是，JSON 规范里并没有明确规定数字的精度上限。你看，这在处理普通的商品价格或者简单的计数时完全没问题，可一旦数字极其庞大，灾难就降临了。
[S02] 我知道你要说哪个案例了，推特也就是现在的X当年就结结实实地撞上了这个墙。
[S01] 对对对，他们系统里当时使用64 位的大数字来作为每条帖子的唯一ID.但是在前端网页最常用的JavaScript语言里，它底层是将所有数字都作为浮点数来处理的。
[S02] 当一个整数大到超过2 的 53 次方时，JavaScript就无法精确表示它了。
[S01] 结果就是，当你用JavaScript写的客户端，通过JSON 请求推特的API 时，拿到的那个超长帖子ID末尾的几位数，因为精度丢失，被强制四舍五入变成了零或者完全错误的数字。
[S02] 可以想象用户有多崩溃。本来想点开一条新闻，结果页面直接跳转到了毫无关联的地方，甚至是404。
[S01] 没错，为了填上这个由JSON 精度引发的超级大坑，推特的API 最后搞出了一个，怎么说呢？极其滑稽的妥协方案。
[S02] 他们在返回的JSON 里，把同一个帖子ID塞了两次。
[S01] 对，一次作为数字传给那些能处理大数的强类型语言后端。另一次呢专门转换成十进制的字符串，好让JavaScript能够当成普通文本，安全地解析出来。
[S02] 这种打补丁的方式，其实就演出了我们系统演化中必须死磕的核心挑战，向后兼容与向前兼容。
[S01] 诶，说到这个，我有个比喻来解释兼容性。向后兼容嘛很好理解，就像是你给奶奶买了个最新的智能手机，她老人家以前存的旧照片、旧联系人，新手机必须得能完美打开。
[S02] 很贴切。那向前兼容呢？
[S01] 向前兼容就像是这台新手机，面对奶奶不小心摁出的某种未知的新功能指令时，即使系统不认识，也绝对不能直接死机崩溃，对吧？
[S02] 完全正确。但在实际的分布式系统中，向前兼容往往是最容易让人翻车的。你想象一个具体的场景，你给用户表中增加了一个叫VIP等级的新字段。
[S01] 嗯，然后新版本的代码把它存进去了。
[S02] 对，紧接着另一台还没来得及升级，仍在运行旧版本代码的服务器，读取了这条记录。
[S01] 可是旧代码的内存模型里根本没有VIP等级的概念啊。
[S02] 没错，如果它只是读出来在页面上展示一下，那忽略掉这个不认识的字段也就罢了。但问题是，如果旧代码需要更新用户的其他信息呢？比如它更新了用户的最后登录时间，然后要把整条记录重新写回数据库。
[S01] 诶，数据的流失就发生在这个瞬间了吧。
[S02] 是的，如果旧代码的系列化机制不够聪明，没有在内存里显示地开辟一块空间，去妥善保存那些他不认识的二进制块。
[S01] 那当他把数据重新打包写回数据库时，那个新代码刚刚添加的VIP等级字段，就会被当成无用的垃圾彻底抹除掉了。
[S02] 业务数据就这样，在系统交替的缝隙里，人间蒸发了。
[S01] 好吧，我们来拆解一下现在的局面，要彻底解决新旧字段在解析时的留存问题，同时又要解决JSON的臃肿和精度陷阱，答案似乎指向了二进制格式。
[S02] 确实，但如果我们只是简单地把JSON压缩成二进制，比如用MESSAGEPACK,其实治标不治本。
[S01] 对，资料里提到一段八十一字节的JSON，最后也只缩小到了六十六字节，为什么呢？因为像username这种长长的英文字段名，依然被逐字逐句的编码进去了。
[S02] 所以我们需要一种更彻比的机制，也就是基于模式或者说SKIMMA驱动的范式转移。
[S01] 也就是把数据的语义和物理存储彻底解耦。Google的PROTOCO BUFFERS也就是大家常说的PROTOBUFF就完美诠释了这种设计。
[S02] PROTOBUFF的智慧在于它丢弃了冗长的字段名。既然发送方和接收方完全可以提前约定好数据的结构，为什么每次传输都要把几十个字节的英文字段名带上呢？
[S01] 对，所以在SKIMMA里直接约定数字标签，标签一就是username，标签二就是FAVORANUMBER.这样在实际在网络中跑的二进制序列里，就再也见不到username这串字母了，取而代之的是极度精简的数字一。
[S02] 没错，而且这正好解决了我们刚才说的向前兼容导致弄丢新字段的致命问题。
[S01] 怎么做到的？
[S02] 当旧代码遇到一个他不认识的新标签，比如标签四，虽然他不知道这个字段代表什么业务逻辑，但PROTOBUFF的底层协议里有一个类型指示器，这个指示器能告诉旧代码，紧跟着的这个标签四占据了多少个字节。
[S01] 哦，所以旧代码就能精准地把这块未知字节原封不动地跳过，并保存在内存里，等写回数据库时，再原样拼接回去。
[S02] 对，这就让系统的演化变得非常安全可控。只要你永远不更改已经分配出去的数字标签，新旧节点就能和平共处。不过在数据压缩的赛道上，PROTOBUFF还不是最极端的。
[S01] 还有更极端的。
[S02] APACHEAVRO,这才是那个把瘦身运动推向极致的怪物。这里最忍辱胜的是AVRO的做法，简直大胆到让人觉得有些疯狂。
[S01] 到底有多疯狂？
[S02] 如果你用AVRO来编满刚才那段数据，它的最终字节流里不仅没有任何英文字段名，竟然连PROTOBUFF里用来救命的数字标签，还有类型指示器全部抛弃了。
[S01] 诶，等一下，连数字标签都不要了。
[S02] 对，它剩下的就是一串纯粹的没有任何结构标识的值的字节拼接。结果就是原本八十一字节的JSON用AVRO编码后，硬生生压成了只有惊人的三十二字节。
[S01] 三十二字节，但这也太离谱了吧。这在工程上立刻引发了一个悖论呐。如果这三十二个字节里连标签和类型都没了，解析器拿到手就是一团乱码，他怎么知道前三个字节是字符串，后四个字节是整数。
[S02] 问得好，就意味着每次解读都必须有一本厚厚的密码本，也就是它那个详细的SKIMMA来作为队长。
[S01] 那不是扯吗？我们在网络上每次只传几十字节的核心数据，却要附带一个几KB大小的密码本，这完全是把网络带宽省下来的空间又浪费在传密码本上了啊，捡了芝麻丢了西瓜。
[S02] 你绝不是第一个这么想的工程师。Avro敢把数据压得这么光秃秃的，是因为它有一套极具针对性的SKIMMA传递策略。解读AVRO数据确实需要并排对比写入者模式和读取者模式来解决差异。
[S01] 那这个巨大的密码本，到底怎么在网络里传递才不亏本？
[S02] 它针对两种主流场景做了不同的取舍。第一种是像HADOOP这样的数据仓库，主要处理包含几百万条记录的大文件。
[S01] 嗯，海量数据导出。
[S02] 对，对于这种场景，AVRO只需要在文件的最开头存一次完整的写入者模式，后面的几百万条数据全是纯粹的极简字节。平摊下来，每条记录携带模式的额外成本几乎为零。
[S01] 好，这种大文件一次性带上说明书我能理解。那如果是数据库呢，或者事件流这种每秒钟有一万条数据零散的随机的写进来的场景，总不能每次都查文件头吧。
[S02] 对于流式场景，业界标准的做法是引入一个专门的模式注册表服务，也就是SKIMMARегистRY.你在每条被压缩到极致的AVRO记录开头，只加上一个极小的版本号。
[S01] 哦，所以读取数据的服务拿到记录后，先看眼版本号，然后去这个注册表里把对应的完整SKIMMA抓取过来，缓存在内存里。
[S02] 没错，之后的所有解读直接在本地光速完成。
[S01] 哇，这就等于把密码本的维护工作外包给了一个专用的档案局。而且你想啊，这种完全不要数字标签，纯靠SKIMMA里的英文字段名来进行对比匹配的设计，对关系型数据库简直是绝配。
[S02] 是的，AVRO对关系型数据库的动态导出超级友好。假设你的表今天增加了一列，明天又删了一列，AVRO可以直接读取最新的表结构，自动生成新的SKIMMA.
[S01] 读取者通过字段名就能自动对齐，再也不需要像PROTOBUFF那样，还需要工程师小心翼翼地去手工维护那些绝对不能冲突的数字标签。
[S02] 对，这就赋予了系统极强的自我演化能力。
[S01] 那么当我们弄懂了数据是如何被精妙地打包压缩，并确保向后和向前兼容之后，我们必须顺着这些数据包的轨迹，去看看它们流经的物流网络。因为在软件架构里，数据的流动不仅跨越了空间，更跨越了时间。
[S02] 你提到时间，资料里有一句非常震撼的金句，数据比代码更长寿。
[S01] 这句话真的有一种残酷的现实感。
[S02] 其实，当你的代码向数据库写入一条记录时，你本质上是在向未来的自己或者未来接收你代码的同事发送一条消息。数据库里可能同时存在五毫秒前和五年前写入的数据。
[S01] 所以，读取历史包袱的能力就是数据库系统的生命线。那如果是跨越空间的流动呢？比如微服务架构里，订单服务去调用支付服务，这中间的数据传递通常是通过RESTAPI或者是RPC来完成的。
[S02] 在网络调用这块，我们必须戳破一个由来已久的架构错觉。Rpc也就是远程过程调用，它诞生的初衷是想让一次跨越千山万水的网络调用，看起来就像调用本地内存里的一个普通函数一样简单。这在学术界被称为未知透明系。
[S01] 这感觉就像RPC试图让你相信点外卖和自己去自家厨房拿吃的是一回事。
[S02] 但这简直是程序员给自己挖的最大的坑。
[S01] 怎么说？
[S02] 你去厨房拿零食，拿到了就拿到了，绝不会出现超时状态。但点外卖时，如果APP提示超时，你根本不知道是餐厅没做，骑手迷路，还是饭已经送到楼下，但骑手手机没电了，你根本不知道饭是没做，还是在半路上丢了。这个外卖的比喻太绝了。如果我们将这与更大的图景联系起来，正因为网络请求有这种不可预测性，当程序遇到超时，最本能的防御反应就是让代码自动重试。
[S01] 但如果餐厅其实已经做好了饭，你一点集重试，餐厅就会给你做两份饭。在支付系统里，这就意味着莫名其妙扣了用户两次钱。
[S02] 所以重试机制必须依赖一个核心概念，密等性，确保同一个扣款请求，无论重试多少次，最终对系统状态的影响只有一次。
[S01] 但如果我们面对的是更复杂的场景呢？有多个服务组成的工作流，比如买一件商品，先调用风控，再调用信用卡网关，最后调用库存发货。
[S02] 这是一个经典的分布式事务难题。
[S01] 对呀，如果这个长长的工作流走到一半，信用卡刚刚扣完款，负责调度的这台主收付器突然断电坑亏了，难道我们要让用户付两次钱吗？最后靠程序员半夜爬起来查日子，人工补救。
[S02] 过去很多年确实是这样，但现在引入了一种叫持续化执行的框架，比如TEMPORAL或者RESTATE,它们能为这种极易坑亏的工作流提供精确一次语义，也就是EXACTLYOWNERS.
[S01] 收付器都断电了，它怎么保证严丝合缝的接上？
[S02] 它们通过记录每一次RPC调用的状态，到外部的高可用数据库里。如果中途坑亏，系统唤醒备用机器从头开始重放，而且重放时会直接跳过那些已经成功的RPC,把当时成功的结果直接喂给代码。
[S01] 诶，等等，既然它坑亏后会把代码重新跑一遍，如果我的代码里写了一句获取当权时间或者生成随机数呢？那第二次重放跑出来的结果不就跟第一次跑的时候不一样了吗？这系统岂不是要精神分裂啊？
[S02] 这引出了一个非常重要的问题，敏敏锐地抓住了重放的漏洞。这就是为什么持续化执行框架强制要求你的代码必须是严格确定性的。
[S01] 确定性的，也就是NONDETERMINISTIC 的代码是绝对不行的。
[S02] 对，非确定性代码是灾难的根源。你不能用语燕自带的随机数或时间函数，必须用框架提供的专用API框架，会在第一次运行时把时间点记录在日志里以后，无论重放多少次，拿到的都是那个历史时间。
[S01] 真的是用极致的约束换取了可靠性啊。那除了持久化执行，面对网络的不确定性，资料还谈到了消息代理或异步解耦，比如卡夫卡或者是ACTOR模型，对吧？
[S02] 没错，区别于必须等待回复的RPC基于消息队列或ACTOR模型的异步通信，起到了完美的解耦和缓冲作用。同步RPC就像打电话，必须立刻接听。消息队列就像发邮件，发出去就算完成，对方什么时候处理，你根本不用管。
[S01] 回顾我们今天的硬核旅程，从推特被64 位数字击穿的尴尬，到AVRO用三十二个字节完成了极致压缩，从把写入数据库视为给未来的自己写信，到看透RPC伪装本地调用的错觉，再到用确定性代码拯救困困状的支付工作流。
[S02] 每一步都是为了在混乱中建立秩序。
[S01] 对，所以下次你在设计API给数据库加字段，或者选择怎么传递数据时，你就不再只是在写代码了。你是在设计一个能在未来几年被自我演化的生命体。不过今天聊到数据比代码更长寿以及持久化执行这种记录每一个不可变状态的系统。最后其实引发了我一个更深层次的思考。
[S02] 哦，什么思考？
[S01] 你想啊，当我们构建的系统越来越擅长记住一切，甚至事无巨细地记录下所有微小的中间状态时，我们是不是在无意中创造了一个数字时代的化石地层？在这个系统里，每一个错误的数据输入，历史的妥协都被永远精确地保存在了某处。
[S02] 这是一个很深刻的哲学问题。
[S01] 是啊，对于一个致力于永远兼容过去记住一切的架构，它的演化阻力可能会越来越大。我们未来又该如何优雅的设计遗忘机制呢？大家可以带着这个关于记忆与遗忘的架构难题，在平时的开发中慢慢琢磨。希望你能从今天的数据之旅中获得全新的灵感。本次深度解析就到这里，我们下次不见不散。